[Musique]
bonjour joseph bellerose
bonjour monsieur caruge bonjour aux
électrices et aux électeurs de
martinique 1ère et tout particulièrement
aux marinoise et omar une oie puisque
vous êtes candidat pour les élections
municipales et communautaires
effectivement dans la ville du marin
alors vous êtes déjà conseiller
municipal d'opposition depuis 2014
d'ailleurs il ya cette particularité
joseph belle rousse et que vous
présentez cette année alors face à
plusieurs candidats mais parmi ces
candidats il y à votre ancien policier
tête de liste en 2014
josé mirande lui-même donc pourquoi
justement vous n'avez pas fait cause
commune cette fois-ci tout à fait vous
avez bien fait de les augmenter mais les
élections de 2014
nous avons cherché à analyser les
raisons pour lesquelles la victoire
n'était pas au beau parce que tout au
long de la campagne nous n'avons entendu
il faut que ça change les gens attendent
un changement mais au sortir dé hume
n'avons pas été majoritaire donc
l'analyse que nous en nous à que nous
avons fait à nous avons à faire remonter
en sorte de choses il ya eu une
abstention record sur le marais donc
nous sommes dit que nous sommes
interrogés sur l'offre électorale
est ce que nous avions répondu à
l'attenté de la population donc sorti au
sortir de cette analyse
j'ai proposé avec des militants des
militants qui vont retrouver que qu'on
change de stratégie au propose une autre
stratégie pour et vu un autre projet
pour à la population pour 2020 mais
c'est là qu'il ya eu divergence
oui il ya peut-être de divergences sur
sur la vision future sur la vision
future jeu
la nouvelle gouvernance que nous voulons
mettre en place alors rodolphe désiré le
maire sortant depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs aux marins ne se présente pas
ne se représente pas est ce que à vos
yeux c'est une formidable opportunité là
qui se présente opportunité je ne sais
pas mais je pense je sais en étant sur
le terrain depuis deux ans en discutant
avec des marines wadan iv un quartier
que après 37 ans de de gouvernance de
cette équipe est bien la population du
marin aspire à changer à tout les la
page de l'histoire du marin et attendent
attendent une nouvelle équipe avec un
projet nouveau alors vous aviez déjà été
conseiller municipal à entre 2001 et
donc vous ne découvrez pas pour ainsi
dire ces affaires-là joseph bellerose
alors de ce point de vue est ce que à
votre sens la ville du marin est en
bonne situation générale at elle connu
un développement efficace au cours des
six dernières années alors je vais dire
que au bar est effectivement et nous
vivons une situation particulière parce
que en poupe on ne peut pas dire que
rien n'a été fait on ne peut pas dire
qu'il n'y a pas eu de développement
puisque au vu et au su de tout le monde
gallo sont geithner ont fait 1
on constate effectivement qu'il ya eu
des réalisations seulement la population
du marin les électeurs les électrices du
marin aujourd'hui ne sont pas tout à
fait en phase avec ce type de
développement attendu que il ya un
contexte économique très difficile sous
le marin nous avons un taux de chômage
important
en dépit de ce développement apparence
l'ailé en fait ce développement n'est
pas pour tous tout le monde n'en
bénéficient pas voilà le fond du
problème
donc c'est un c'est une ceinture
questionnement donc et new marais
l'équipe que j'ai l'honneur de présider
qui s'appelle le marin unis eh bien nous
nous sommes penchés sur cette question
et nous pensons apporter des repas leur
pour les six ans à venir mais
précisément pour remédier à eux cela
qu'est né le projet symbolique de votre
liste justement joseph bellerose alors
projet symbolique ce site était facile
aujourd'hui de lister une série de
réalisations bon mais nous sommes pas
dans cette logique parce que nous disons
rien de durable ne peut se faire si on
n'a pas des finances si on en est on ne
s'assoit pas sur un équilibre financier
aujourd'hui la ville du marin tout le
monde le sait est dans le collimateur de
l'assemblée régionale des comptes
donc nous avons jusqu'ici on respecte
les recommandations de l'action
régionale des comptes nous avons jusqu'à
2000 31 décembre 2021 pour retourner à
l'équilibré ne voulait pas mettre la
charrue avant les boeufs pour ainsi dire
tout à fait d'abord assainir la
situation budgétaire est la priorité des
priorités ensuite ensuite de
rassemblement on définit avec la
population les priorités des priorités
des réalisations que nous devons mettre
en place mais aujourd'hui lorsque vous
faites me côtoient aussi vous avez dans
les quartiers et bien tout le monde ils
vous disent bien
mais au bout il ya des choses à faire
les choses à fait d'accord mais voilà
mais il faut d'abord donc savoir de
quels moyens disposent exactement tout
en vous a compris merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions joseph bellerose danse à
oka dix spéciales initiales
oui ces cinq minutes les cinq minutes
sont déjà passés mais bien sûr ça passe
très vite émission réalisée par adele
qui est dit
[Musique]